what a difference a year makes these are
satellite images for july this year and
12 months ago england's green pastures
turned brown
met office stats show southern england
had just 10 millimeters of rain in july
the driest in records back to 1836
before even queen victoria was on the
throne so how does the current situation
compare to 1976 an exceptional drought
year when people got their water from
stand
our map shows that july's rainfall in
the southeast corner of the country this
year has been well below the levels of
1976.
what about the year so far after all
droughts are the result of months of dry
weather well let's look at kent where
the cumulative rainfall total for 2022
is well below the long term average but
so far it's still higher than 1976.
now of course temperatures this summer
have been much higher and that's left
the landscape parched
latest data from the environment agency
shows the soil in devon and cornwall is
close to its driest ever for the time of
year
river levels at the end of july were
also exceptionally low in many parts of
the country the thames in windsor had
the lowest flow on record so did the
crane brent and ingreborn in london and
in east anglia the wave knee little ooze
and eely ooze where water was just five
percent of the long-term average
levels in the underground aquifers that
supply water to millions of people are
also falling in many areas they're
exceptionally low in monitoring sites in
the cotswolds and the south downs and
reservoir levels are falling fast as
demand for water has soared aardingly in
sussex and the lower thames reservoirs
have never been lower than this at this
time of year
much of england is short of water and
with august expected to be dry in the
south it is only going to get worse